okay so one of the questions for uh like
a year i guess but particularly in the
last three to four months is what is
happening at the justice department
under the stewardship of attorney
general merrick garland why is there not
uh investigation criminal investigation
going on of at least some of the things
that former president donald trump did
uh we have now received confirmation
from the attorney general merrick
garland that the justice department
indeed received
um information about the classified
records found among the documents
recovered from trump's mar-a-lago and
that the justice department is looking
into it now uh this colloquially means
that they are investigating whether this
would technically be called an open
criminal investigation is a question
mark um npr reporting attorney general
merrick garland said the justice
department is aware that classified
material has been found on trump's
mar-a-lago property but didn't
explicitly confirm a federal probe is
underway
um let's take a look at the video clip
this is during a press conference the
audio is not great but i think we will
be able to make out what's being said
question
last week the national archives revealed
that it found classified information in
15 boxes of documents stored at
mar-a-lago is the justice department
investigating to determine how the how
that classified information got during
who might have accessed it so as uh
as the archivist said in a letter that
was sent to the congress uh the national
archives has informed the justice
department of this and communicated with
it uh and we will do what we always do
under these circumstances
look at the facts and law and take it
from there so
you know it he's using very careful
language he says we have received the
information
and we are going to
do what we always do we're going to look
at the facts and we're going to look at
the law now i think he's being very
careful here he is not saying we have
opened a federal investigation because
that's very specific and formal language
he is saying
we are investigating and at this point
is this merely a semantic question it
may be because i see no interest
whatsoever
in seriously
um uh
looking at the possibility of indicting
donald trump i mean i just i just don't
see it so
the fact that he's informally saying
there's an investigation without calling
it a federal probe i think is not
ultimately going to be super meaningful
now of course at this point there would
be a real question for all the people
who back in 2016 said i'm not voting for
hillary i'm voting for trump because
hillary can't be trusted with sensitive
information hillary can't be trusted
with classified information or emails
the private email server etc etc
those people should now be saying wow
if those were my concerns with hillary i
never should have voted for donald trump
but if you actually go and talk to them
the vast majority
will just excuse away this behavior and
say it's not really that bad or trump
was justified in doing it or it's a
witch hunt or the claims are untrue or
whatever the case may be i've even seen
uh online
some conservative uh
they're not even really conservative
some trumpian reactionaries saying
trump did everything right here trump's
own people found the classified
documents and called the national
archives and said hey guys we've got
this stuff you should come and get it
really quickly there is
no evidence that that's what took place
right the the narrative they want to
create is
trump had no idea about these documents
and um trump staff found them and
immediately of their own volition called
the national archives and said come and
get the documents of course there is no
evidence that that is the story but at
the end of the day
i don't believe merrick garland has any
interest in indicting a former president
and the fact that they are generally
investigating without confirming an open
federal probe
is a distinction
but i don't think it will make a
functional difference in terms of what
we are to expect if you think garland
might have an appetite for indicting
trump
let me know i've seen no evidence to
suggest that that's the case